الى موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يعد سلاح
ذو حدين حقيقه مشاهدينا قاعده اثبتها
الروبوتس تابع لشركه مايكروسوفت عندما خرج
عن السيطره وذلك بعد ان هدد بهندسه فيروس
قاتل واختراق اجهزه كمبيوتر وسرقه رموز
نوويه وصولا طبعا الى التفريق بين الزوج
وزوجته كما فعل مع مراسل شبكه نيوز هذه
الحادثه اثارت مخاوف الباحثين والعلماء
حول العالم وطبعا تخيفنا ايضا هنا من
المهم جدا الاضاءه على مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي رغم اهميتها ما هو الذكاء
الاصطناعي وماذا يحمل هو يحمل اثارا سلبيه
لا بل كارثيه على الانسان وايضا على حقوقه
وفق تحذير مفوضيه الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان التي ابدت مخاوفها من ان هذا
التطور الذي تشهده اجهزه الذ الاصطناعيه
خصوصا لجهه عدم القدره على التحكم بها او
السيطره عليها ومع استمرار وتيره ثوره
التكنولوجيا تشير التقديرات الى ان ملايين
الموظفين والعمال سوف يفقدون وظائفهم هذا
فيما يخص العمل لكن خبراء في الذكاء
الاصطناعي في المجالين الصناعي والاكاديمي
حذروا ايضا من خلال ورقه بحثيه من ان هذا
القطاع سيؤثر سلبا ايضا على الجنس البشري
حقيقه كما شددوا على ان الاستخدام المزدوج
وقدره الاجهزه التقنيه على اتخاذ القرارات
المعقده في الثانيه الواحده يمكن
استخدامها في النقدين اما لمنفعه الناس
واما لاذائهم اكثر من ذلك مشاهدينا الخطر
الاكبر الذي يهدد البشريه هو مصارعه الدول
الكبرى الى استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل
واسع للاغراض العسكريه
وهو ما تفعله خصوصا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه روسيا الصين التي خصصت ميزانيات
ضخمه لهذا الغرض كما انها ترفض فرض حظر
على هذه الاسلحه او تقييد استخدامها وهنا
يطرح التساؤل المخيف هل من الممكن ان
يسيطر علينا الذكاء الاصطناعي ويتحكم بنا
قريبا لنرى
[موسيقى]